while it's the year 2023 and still
thousands of people in Clark County are
not connected to the internet at home at
least the governor's office says it's
doing its best to navigate these
obstacles to get these individuals
connected 8 news now reporter Ryan
Matthey joins us live with the digital
divide and how they're trying to bridge
it Ryan
yeah Kirsten Denise we're in area code
89183 here in Clark County it has one of
the largest disconnects between
low-income families who qualify for free
internet but don't actually get it and
as Broadband is becoming more of a
necessity work is being done to connect
low-income families who are still not
connected I enjoy it though I'm learning
the 68 year old Abdul Shahbaz has lived
in the historic West Side for nearly two
decades and should I pay for this or buy
some food or whatever but when he needed
to use the internet the library was his
only option a half hour walk away he
says he couldn't afford another monthly
cost at home it really brings it really
home to you in terms of you involved now
you don't feel like you isolated this is
one low-income household out of
thousands in Nevada that qualify for
free high-speed home internet through
the federal affordable connectivity
program nearly 500 000 Nevada households
are eligible but just 40 percent are
enrolled in Clark County just over half
of those eligible are enrolled
affordability is a big is a big obstacle
Brian Mitchell director for the Nevada
governor's office of science Innovation
and Technology says the program
additionally helps those eligible get a
computer even if you build the fastest
internet connection to someone's house
if they can't afford it then they're
just as unconnected as they would be
living in you know the mountains in the
middle of nowhere we don't get a list
with who's eligible for this program but
Jana uthman Market VP for Cox
Communications says people are unaware
that they qualify and but it is
literally a door sometimes a door by
door effort while they overcome these
obstacles people like Shabazz are
staying connected without breaking the
bank I'm grateful for it myself it's
really really
now through this program the federal
government offers those 30 dollars a
month discount on Internet services
that's the take into businesses like Cox
who offers the internet services for
that amount reporting live in the South
Valley Ryan Matthey 8 News Now